un député républicain de plus un député
de la droite et du centre de plus ça
sera plus autorité plus d'ordre c'est
pour ça qu'ils se battront à l'assemblée
nationale c'est ce que nous faisons
aussi aujourd'hui au sénat et c'est pour
ça que je fais campagne de toutes mes
forces dans les autres ans mais aussi
partout en france je serai en gironde
cet après-midi pour justement apporter
mon soutien tous ses collègues
aujourd'hui le meilleur rempart contre
les extrêmes contre la gauche
mélenchonistes ce sont les candidats de
la droite et du centre d'ailleurs vous
parliez tout à l'heure du ministre
d'éducation et nous racontons pas
d'histoires en niveau clair c'est aussi
un clin d'oeil de monsieur macron à la
gauche mélenchonistes est le meilleur
rempart parce que nos candidats les
sortants et un certain nombre de ceux
qui sont en conquête sont des ducs sont
implantés les législatives c'est une
élection nationale je le sais mais tous
ceux qui sont sortants il était
sacrément costaud pour être élu re la
fois dernière c'est parce qu'ils ont un
ancrage populaire et c'est ce qui fait
la différence au second tour si on veut
éviter la gauche mélenchon nice c'est un
candidat et l'eire qui est le mieux
placé dans calais ça bouge encore ben
évidemment et plus nous serons nombreux
plus nous pourrons plus fort et plus
rapidement rebondir et repartir parce
que nos idées sont toujours là et nos
candidats aussi